США вже з усіх боків обклали "Північний потік-2" санкціями і тиснуть на Берлін в цьому питанні.
Але офіційний Берлін досі залишався непохитним. Навіть коли улітку стало відомо про отруєння Олексія Навального
і всі вже подумки поховали проєкт газопроводу, уряд Німеччини заявив, що політику з економікою плутати не варто.
Однак з арештом Навального уперше тональність Берліна дещо змінилася.
Принаймні офіційний речник уряду ФРН Штеффен Зайберт визнав,
що доля суперечливого газопроводу може стати частиною санкційного пакету через Навального.
Євросоюз це наразі саме обговорює.
- Декілька днів тому в цьому місці федеральна канцлерка заявила,
що поки не досягнуто точки, коли слід взагалі дискутувати про продовження будівництва "Північного потоку-2".
Не вважаєте, що нині цей момент настав? Адже Ви щойно казали про жорстокість,
з якою поводилася російська поліція, та неправомірність вироку.
Так… і думаю, що ці слова були чітким та ясними.
І це причина, чому ми з європейськими партнерами будемо обговорювати, як нам на це реагувати.
Я щойно згадав: торік у жовтні були санкції. І про них слід поговорити.
Щодо "Північного потоку-2" - я казав про це багаторазово і не лише я -
позиція уряду ФРН відома. І вона не змінилася.
Ідея зупинити "Північний потік-2" знаходить дедалі більше прихильників у Німеччині.
На початку цього тижня відмовитися від проєкту через Навального закликала Франція, одна з головних союзниць Німеччини.
Тим не менше навіть опозиційні німецькі партії не виключають,
що "Північний потік-2" все ж може бути добудований, адже пов'язаний
з фінансовими ризиками для самої Німеччини:
Для зупинки "Північного потоку- 2" необхідно одностайне рішення Європейської ради.
Я вважаю це малоймовірним через ставлення до цього питання Німеччини, Австрії та деяких інших країн ЄС.
Якщо Німеччина сама зважиться на зупинку газогону, без європейських санкцій,
вона буде зобов’язана відшкодувати фінансові збитки. Саме тому я сумніваюся, що це трапиться.
Я ніколи не був прибічником цього проєкту, але ціна його зупинки для ФРН
в даний момент була б, імовірно, дуже високою.
При цьому залишається під питанням, чи досягли б ми бажаного ефекту,
оскільки у Росії достатньо можливостей експортувати свій газ в інші способи.
Повну компенсацію збитків за припинення російсько-німецького газопроєкту
однією лише Німеччиною Юрґен Тріттін назвав економічною катастрофою,
адже йдеться про мільярди доларів відшкодувань.
У правлячому блоці ХДС/ХСС позиція щодо "Північному потоку-2" схожа:
У моїй партії завжди були дуже скептично налаштовані щодо цього проєкту -
як з економічного, так і з зовнішньополітичного боку.
Я ніколи не виступав за цей проєкт від самого початку.
Але ми повинні зрозуміти, де ми перебуваємо:
незадовго до завершення будівництва, на яке є всі дозволи.
Його скасування, ймовірно, призведе до виплати збитків у розмірі мільярдів доларів.
Інше питання - якщо йтиметься взагалі про замороження закупівлі нафти й газу в Росії на Заході,
гадаю, у нас буде серйозна розмова на цю тему.
У відповідь на критику США німецька влада неодноразово вказувала,
що Вашингтон і сам підтримує російський режим закупівлею російської нафти.
Один з критиків "Північного потоку-2" в Бундестазі, член комітету із зовнішньої політики Рената Альт
пропонує ще один варіант: заморозити проєкт, поки російський уряд
не дасть відповіді щодо ситуації з Навальним і масових порушень прав людини на мітингах ц Росії.
Я не вважаю, що тут повинен бути довгобуд.
Проєкт буде добудований, проте будівництво має бути призупинено до моменту,
поки російська сторона не прояснить отруєння Олексія Навального.
Поки цього не зроблено і поки протести в Росії так жорстко придушуються, будівництво слід заморозити.
Не можна просто спостерігати за тим, як "Північний потік - 2" нині продовжує будуватися.
Адже йдеться про свободу, права людини, демократію, якої хочуть у Росії.
Через це саме нині країнам Європейського Союзу важливо виступити спільно,
щоб це насильство і жорстокість були засуджені.
Раніше німецька газета ділових кіл Німеччини Handelsblatt повідомила про можливу угоду між США і Німеччиною,
за якої Вашингтон може відмовитися від санкцій проти "Північного потоку-2",
якщо Німеччина гарантує механізм блокування газопроводу - за необхідності.
Наприклад, у разі, якщо Москва буде скорочувати обсяги поставок через ГТС України для тиску на Київ.
Однак офіційного підтвердження цих відомостей ані з Вашингтона, ані з Берліна поки немає.
А поки політики вирішують долю проєкту, "Північний потік-2" вже майже добудований.
Залишилося прокласти півтори сотні кілометрів труб.
Тут, у німецькому Лубміні, газопровід виходить з Балтійського моря на поверхню.
Приймальний термінал для російського газу готовий до експлуатації ще з літа.
Сухопутне продовження трубопроводу теж незабаром можна буде використовувати на повну потужність.
І тим не менше мер Лубміна Аксель Фоґт побоюється, що "Північний потік-2" можуть ніколи не запустити.
Для нас це стане жахливою антирекламою, якщо проєкт обернеться банкрутством для інвесторів,
а політичні дискусії будуть і надалі вестися в такому тоні.
Я боюся, що це відлякає від нас тих інвесторів, яких ми могли б зацікавити.
У Європі на шальках терезів опинилися, з одного боку, Навальний і жорстке придушення протестів,
з іншого - велетенський енергетичний проєкт з Росією.
Своєю політикою президент Путін може зруйнувати своє ж дітище.